die klausel vom teufel sie hier in
berlin treibt seit wochen ihr unwesen
und ist nicht nur hier in deutschland in
den schlagzeilen aber jetzt dreht sie
völlig durchgreift eine frau und ihrem
hund an
bis jetzt hatte sie mächtig schweinen
die klausel vom berliner grunewald die
im august bundesweit zum star wurde
klaute sie doch einem nacktbader seinen
laptop den dieser durch heldenhaften
einsatz allerdings zurückerobern konnte
gut für den fkk aber schlecht für das
wildschwein hätte es doch sonst
ergoogeln können dass sein abschuss
geplant ist und dass seine berliner fan
boys und girls deswegen auf die
barrikaden gingen
die freunde der klausel bekommen nun
allerdings ein man könnte sagen problem
moralischer art soll ihr staat auf
wieder zugeschlagen haben
aber diesmal blutig die bache soll den
hund einer spaziergängerin angegriffen
haben und zwar so stark dass das tier zu
verenden droht sollten die vorwürfe
zutreffen was noch zu beweisen ist wird
das populäre wildschwein wohl spätestens
mit beginn der jagdsaison ins kreuzfeuer
geraten nicht mehr nur in das der kritik
sondern in das der berliner jäger und
ihr mann mein kollege ist jetzt bei dem
frauchen das verletzten hundes wir sind
hier am berliner teufelssee wo die
wildschweine ja zur berühmtheit com sind
und mit mir ist hier catherine das ist
die das frauchen von flummi einem 14
jährigen blonden afghan und kerstin
erzählen sie mal was gestern hier
passiert ist
naja ich war mit meiner freundin heidi
baden ganz normal wir hatten uns
eigentlich den tag freigenommen und ein
bisschen nett gemacht die wildschweine
war natürlich auch da die waren ganz mal
wieder auf der badewiese sind da
umtriebig gewesen und haben dort wieder
geguckt ob sie etwas ändern können
können und sind dann aber abgezogen weil
zu wenig leute da waren dann sind wir um
die mittagszeit auch hier weg gegangen
mit meinem hund wie gesagt er ist jetzt
nicht so dass der grob auffällig wird
oder die für schweine eine bedrohung
darstellt weil er sich hektisch bewegt
sondern
der ist er hier sehr sehr langsam hinter
uns hinterher geschlichen
dann sind wir diesen weg hier diese
zuwegung weiter bis zur etwa zaun kannte
vor da wo wir gleich ankommen und dann
schoss praktisch die bache komplett aus
dem wald raus aber nicht etwa auf
unserem hund zu der ein paar meter
hinter uns liefern sich sozusagen etwa
sechs bis acht meter werden mir musste
auch nicht ausschließen weil wieder
schon kennen und schoss auf meine
freundin zu auf die frau müller die
neben mir lief und ich gehe mal davon
aus dass der hintergrund der wahl weil
sie hatte gepäck dabei und durch die ich
habe ein riesen aufstand gemacht die
arme hochgerissen und geschrien dann ist
die im rasenden galopp diesem weg
gelangt und hat denn hier praktisch sich
auf meinen hund gestürzt ist seitlich an
den rand den umgeschmissen und hat dann
angefangen massiv ihn
man kann wirklich sagen zu zerfleischen
wir konnten ihn dann nur noch aufheben
und zum auto tragen und in die klinik
fahren ist dann gestern noch notoperiert
worden ist jetzt stabil
aber ich bin sehr froh dass er lebt und
sehr sehr glücklich darüber weil das
eigentlich große debakel an der ganzen
sache ist dass ist um den hund gar nicht
ging die bache hat sich nicht für den
hund interessiert sondern mehr für uns
das gepäck und ist wie gesagt da massiv
aus dem wald heraus geschnellt und also
ich weiss nicht was sagen weiter
vorgefallen wäre wenn wir uns nicht
gewehrt hätten und die angst eingejagt
hatte dass das ist ein umstand der tätig
und das mit dem hund geht schon mal das
geht logischerweise für mich persönlich
nicht aber die ganze sache mit dem mit
der wache nimmt mittlerweile formen an
die nicht nur leute die hier einfach
ganz harmlos spazieren gehen wollen
schockt sondern auch die leute die hier
am wasser liegen
und das hauptproblem ist halt dass es am
tage ist nicht nicht nachts spazieren
jeder berliner weiß dass man am abend
nicht spazieren geht ganz einfach weil
wir bald gebiete haben und die tiere
nachtaktiv sind sondern andere qualität
jetzt letzte frage noch wie geht's jetzt
flummi den blonden aufgaben ich habe
gerade eine andere
bekommen aus der klinik bin sehr sehr
froh er sein zustand ist stabil er hat
erst mal überlebt wir müssen jetzt
gucken dass er die nächsten tage schafft
und dann mal sehen auf jeden fall hoffe
ich dass mein hund nicht verliere und da
ist mir jetzt erstmal es war jedes jesus
dieses geld recht aber da kommen noch
richtig somit zu das muss man schon
sagen ja okay also das ist die situation
hier am teufelssee die lustige klausel
hat jetzt ist jetzt leider aggressiv
geworden dass hatten ja auch die
wildtier experten erwartet dass so etwas
passieren könnte und jetzt muss man
schauen wie mit der situation umgegangen
wird
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dir das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren